[Musique]
les héros de louis pergaud les héros de
la guerre des boutons certes ne
possédait pas eu de cheval mais avait
dit besoin de chevaux pour être des
guerriers comme les autres et les
guerriers sans doute aussi chevaleresque
aussi violent aussi épique que les
personnages de au maire de rappeler que
les personnages de la chanson de rolland
ne serait ce que par l'abondance la
couleur et la sonorité des injures
qu'ils échangent ses héros de la guerre
des boutons qui viennent de vivre en
images qui vivent en ce moment sur les
écrans de france grâce au film de yves
robert
yves robert s'ils voulaient bien venir
jusqu'à moi il relève pourquoi ce film
pourquoi cette passion pour ce livre
est-ce que c'est justement parce que
c'est un livre épique je prends du
plaisir le mot oui il ya plusieurs
raisons la guerre des boutons a été
d'abord pour moi titre mystérieux quand
j'étais enfant
en faisant ce que j'ai rempli des pages
et des dictées où je faisais beaucoup de
fautes et signé louis pergaud et entre
parenthèses la guerre des boutons ça
paraissait mystérieux ce type la guerre
des boutons puisque ça voulait dire
et puis plus grands j'ai lu la guerre
des boutons facebook le premier livre
que j'ai lu de mon propre choix en ce
sens que grâce aux émissions et avant
vos émissions il y avait d'autres genres
pour conseiller les enfants je trouve
que par exemple jules verne c'est la
lecture dirigée on est bien forcé de
lire je le verrai quand on est un petit
garçon tandis que lincou j'ai découvert
louis pergaud comme ça et puis j'ai
découvert la guerre des boutons et sur
les quais je devais avoir 13 ans en
fouillant parce que j'étais assez
curieux et des courriels et y avoir de
moments avant et là je commence à
briller sur les tgv ce titre via les
boutons bienvenues comme une enseigne
lumineuse et jets privés
je les prix avaient gelé t'es acheté je
crois et puis je les lui alors qu'est ce
que c'est que c'est ok qu'est ce qui
vous a passionné dans cette guerre aux
beaucoup de choses d'abord jeune garçon
se bat partiel et parce que ça m'a
rappelé des mamans jamais vécu enfant je
vécu à la campagne et nous aussi on
faisait la guerre avec les grandes la
prévière ou avec les garçons de l'école
boulle école laïque sur vent les
suivants les revers de fortune de mes
parents et puis je vais tenir et d'y
appeler la cause de cela cause de la
guerre plus qu'au moins dans les
villages et plus ou moins mystérieuse
rocks un excès de santé qui fait qu'on
déteste villages voisins ou qu'on a une
haine toute amicale d'ailleurs qui se
terminent généralement au moment des
conscrits et comme dit pergaud par une
une fête général et mais quand on était
enfant il n'y a vu que maintenant que
les jeunes gens et les enfants pour
défendre cette espèce d'honneur et qui
chaque année revient dans la guerre des
boutons chaque année à la rentrée des
classes
eh bien on trouve une raison x ou y pour
recommencer la guerre mais c'est un
grand jeu c'est un grand jeu merveilleux
et auxquelles on croit beaucoup plus que
quand on joue entre camarades à la
guerre et on désigne toi tu seras
l'ennemi moi je serai l'autre ennemi
là on a des vrais ennemis mais perd
goldie bien et le montre bien dans des
écrits plus tardif que la guerre des
boutons qu'elle a écrit un roman qui
s'appelle vraiment qu'il a commencé que
j'appelle le bras du front ou le braquer
fiancée avec lointier le chef des longer
le mur et le verbe de vie des fiancés
avec l'une des soeurs d'un de ses
adversaires d'avant alors voyez que
c'était surtout un grand grand jeu un
surcroît de santé il ne faut pas croire
que la guerre sera toujours la guerre
parce que les enfants se battent c'est
absurde
oui comment est ce que les enfants alors
conçoivent la guérison par rapport aux
adultes et une façons comme louise
infiniment plus plus saine parce que je
crois qu'ils savent ce qu'ils font
oui c'est ça continuer d'y croire eux
savent ce qu'ils font
oui il ya également jour chez eux
comment définiriez-vous par exemple le
chef qui est sous le bras
renier tout à l'heure et qui est
important à c'est un personnage
extrêmement intéressant c'est une étude
de personnages de la part de perco car
pergaud se penche sur le monde des
enfants mais en fait nous décrit les
adultes
peut-être avec plus de franchise parce
que mes enfants ni ne connaissent pas
encore tous les détours des adultes
alors le menteur chez pertes chez les
enfants et menteur l'homme juste
l'enfant geste est juste le triste et
risque de savants et ce avant celle et
chez les adultes en arrange ça en fait
tiffany gandhi où on arrive à se montrer
à peu près normale tout le monde est
normal c'est un coup très ennuyée
puisque pierre les de l'opposition
justement des adultes et des enfants y
jouent d'événements qui est très
important qu'il faut signaler ne serait
ce que parce que ceux d'hier n'est
peut-être pas destinée comme on dit est
remis dans les mains des plus jeunes où
il ya ces injures dont je parlais tout à
l'heure où ce langage extrêmement
colorés et grossi il faut bien dire
qu'il employait couramment par ses
enfants
il ya sûrement quelque chose à dire a su
soyons justes soyons honnêtes soyons
francs on surprend jeux des enfants les
parents sur panne les enfants à venir
des mots grossiers
shana ça aucune gravité ayant les
enfants blêmissent ou vers l'iss devant
les parents ma ville à 10 me rappellerai
monfils qui devais avoir 7 ans tient en
haut de l'escalier à traiter un petit
copain de salo est en fait c'était moi
le petit copain il avait confondu et
l'ombre et il a verdi et j'ai souri et
puis ça s'est très bien arranger je
crois que si vous voulez dans ce domaine
là avec les enfants il faut avoir une
autorité pleine d'humour sans ça on ne
s'y retrouve pas alors pergaud a eu la
franchise et d'honnêteté de faire parler
les enfants comme ils parlent entre eux
car quand des enfants quittent la maison
l'école l'église où tous ceux qui les
règles eh bien ils retrouvent elles qui
se retrouvent avec leur père avec leurs
copains eh bien ils sont sûrement plus
authentique que enfermés dans les règles
donc je parlais c'est sûr ça il ne faut
pas se faire d'illusions et je crois que
personne aucun pédagogue
aucun parent ne peut se faire cette
illusion vi a là aucun aucune gravité
pérou a ajouté que ces espèces de
surcroît de vie se lit mon la ville des
contrats bien et montrera bien la vérité
des personnages ont dit des enfants
quand ils se comportent comme ça quel
hypocrite mais je crois que les vrais
d'hypocrites sont ceux qui les empêche
de se montrer tels qu'ils sont et le
même si ces enfants passent leurs
journées à la guerre cela ne signifie
pas qu'il soit viennent en profondément
c'est à dire qu'elle est la conclusion
du vivre et la conclusion du film
la conclusion du livre et que dans
pergaud le la guerre éternelle entre les
deux villages et qu'on recommencera
l'année prochaine quand les parents
auront oublié puisque les parents ont
découvert le pot-aux-roses et qu'en fait
les grands disons par les parents les
grands sont en fait le véritable ennemi
est bien la guerre s'arrêtera et puis en
commençant l'année prochaine quand les
grands oubliés mais nous nous avions
peur de cette réflexion avec françois
boyer l'auteur de jeu interdits qui a
adapté diago dialoguer le film et dieu
sait s'il l'a fait avec amour et l'amour
de pergaud nous avons trouvé à travers
les écrits perd coup nous sommes permis
de donner une autre conclusion au livre
pas du tout
la dernière phrase est la même mais les
deux héros les deux chefs des deux
bandes se retrouvent après différentes
péripéties en pension et comme ils sont
seuls en pension dans cette espèce de
cage pour un enfant eh bien ils se
retrouvent ils tombent dans les bras
l'un de l'autre et des visions les
adversaires mais je crois que c'est
quand on a un authentique adversaire
honnête francs eh bien on l'est
[Musique]